another point that occurred to me after
the show yesterday we talked about it on
pftpm last night shereen williams and i
this to me for the cardinals suggests
that they're bracing for larry
fitzgerald to retire because j.j
watt fills that void of having
statesman guy with gravitas nfl man of
the year
it balances out having larry fitzgerald
walk away if that's what larry
fitzgerald does we still don't know what
he's going to do
but it's march 3rd and he hasn't said
he's never gone this long without saying
and it won't surprise me if he calls it
a career
but if he's out you've got a larry
fitzgerald type of a figure
kind of a respected guy that
everyone looks up to now that that takes
the place
of the guy that everyone looks up to who
potentially is going to be walking away
well i i definitely think there's value
in that i mean
you're right i never really thought
about that or connected the dots but
that certainly makes sense it does
um but but i but i think more than
anything i go back to
it's a you know it's a familiarity thing
with the vance joseph
j.j watt right it's hey you know my
system
hey you can sell my system to these guys
hey you know show these guys how to work
after practice and
maybe show them how to get out early a
little bit before practice when you
start doing little technique things with
your hands and all the hand fighting and
all of those type of things
and there's a real need on their front
seven like we talked about
not only for you know an f the play up a
guy that can disrupt and do
all that but i think you know what you
just already mentioned
yeah booty buddha baker is a star he's
awesome
um but he is young and maybe he's not a
rah-rah vocal leader type guy chandler
jones
i've been around chandler a lot he's an
awesome guy he can be a dominating force
on the football field but he's a quiet
personality in the locker room and off
the field
he's great teammate you love him but i
don't know if he's necessarily the guy
that's like hey guys let's get over here
let me show you how to do this and hey
you could be better
at that and do those type of things and
that's where i think jjy
the value uh along with the play is real
there and the cardinals do need that it
was definitely a need of improvement in
that area for their football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports